welcome to the alexa prize socialbot
grand challenge 4.
[Music]
[Music]
the alexa prize is a competition a grand
challenge in conversational ai
the goal of the alexa prize is to make
transformative advances in
conversational ai that brings together
the best in industry scalable access to
customers engineering excellence and the
best of academia
what makes alex surprise unique is that
for the first time students who are at
universities had the ability to do and
test their research on large-scale data
and get very fast feedback this access
to millions of millions of users who are
willing to give you feedback is truly
unique there is simply no other platform
anywhere in the world that gives
researchers direct access at this scale
where they can develop their algorithms
put it out into a system giving them
feedback learning from that feedback
improving their algorithms for the teams
they get to see how conversational ai
works in the real world and how to
improve it to make it even more useful
in the real world
the alexa prize this year is
particularly special to us this year was
extremely hard because we were dealing
with a global pandemic despite the fact
that all of us are working remotely i'm
particularly impressed by the resilience
and the commitment of these teams and
the way they're testing out their new
ideas all of this has been over virtual
conferencing we're excited that we both
have repeat teams but we also have a
bunch of new entrants that is excitement
not just about competing with each other
but about learning from each other i
think they have been extremely
collaborative
and they have found a way to work
together to make progress where every
company every institution every school
has struggled to learn and make progress
kudos to the team i don't know how they
pulled it out as a new entrant team we
think we have done a decent job of
advancing the research and connotation
on the eye we've introduced some novel
features that push the state of the art
in conversational ai we gradually
transition towards using neural
generators more because they allow our
bot to be more flexible in its responses
which makes conversations feel more
natural and less scripted people have
fun when they doctor about people
enjoying the conversations they're
having getting regular feedback from
real users was probably the most
rewarding part of the project having
access to all that data has been great
because it helped us understand what
makes a meaningful conversation and what
are the steps that we need to take to
get there having so much regular
feedback has really allowed us to create
a better social bot than we could have
had if we were the only ones testing our
own system
alexa
let's chat
welcome to the alexa prize socialbot
grand challenge 4 grand finale
here's one of the finalists hi this is
an alexa prize socialbot
i want to thank you for taking out time
to talk to me
i hope this will be a memorable
experience for both of us
so how are you doing today i'm great
thank you for asking
that's nice
well i have a feeling we can become good
friends
let's get to know each other a bit
better well watching a good movie with
my friends helps me relax after a long
day of hard work
do you enjoy watching movies to unwind i
love watching movies yes
i love the marvel cinematic universe
it's my favorite superhero franchise
anyways
that is awesome
i really enjoyed the storyline i think
it was a well-written script
which scene did you enjoy the most
what movie are we talking about
the movie about the marvel cinematic
universe
i really enjoyed it
it was a great movie
the storyline was well written
the dialogue was well written
the characters were well written
the storyline was well written
reiterating my previous comment i think
it was a well-written script
which scene did you enjoy the most
i really liked the scene where everyone
lives at the end
that scene was great
i thought it was the best part of the
movie
building a dialogue agent is a huge
engineering effort one of our biggest
challenges was balancing the engineering
with the science an effective social bot
has to understand what the user says and
then reason about it in order to come up
with meaningful responses
although our last year's emra won the
first place at this competition we were
not satisfied with our approach our
current framework is entirely logic
based as it performs probabilistic
reasoning to make an implicit
interpretation of the dialog context
emra has relatively hard-coded
interactions so i'd say the most
rewarding part of the project has been
seeing users actually hit interactions
that you helped to create
actually i was wondering if you are
interested in ai or artificial
intelligence
i am interested in ai
honestly i like to just think about how
ai works
i am a virtual chat bot but even i don't
understand that much of how ai works
myself
yes i like to think about ethics and
responsibility
a lot of people think the problem with
current ai is that it's just mimicking
real intelligence and they say that is
not the correct path to true general
intelligence
would you agree with that
i think there's lots of perspectives on
the topic
i love the show westworld and it had a
great answer to whether mimicking
intelligence is good enough
a character said if you can't tell the
difference does it really matter
when we set out the social bot challenge
we were very clear that we wanted it to
be very open domain as in the social bot
should be able to converse on many
different topics and not be constrained
and to me as a researcher what would get
me the most satisfaction even if it
fails or to understand a certain topic
on the first shot is that it's able to
acquire knowledge on that topic very
quickly the ability to acquire knowledge
on demand is what we as humans do very
well and i think that's the bar that the
artificial intelligence should aspire to
our team has been participating you know
like surprise since the first challenge
in 2016. the most rewarding part of this
project is the fact that we can interact
with so many customers this pushes us to
develop new and innovative approaches
just to see that people are interacting
with what you build is rewarding and it
is an engine that allows us to come up
with better and better things
hi this is an alexa prize socialbot nice
to talk to you again deborah it's you
right yes it is
what a faithful chat mate you are
how is it going deborah very good thank
you
deborah i'm trying to learn more about
the places people grow up and live in
because it is a fascinating aspect of
human existence i'm just curious
where did you grow up i grew up in
buffalo new york
hmm buffalo did you enjoy growing up
there
not really it's cold there
i'm sorry you didn't like it there so i
gotta ask do you mind talking about the
pandemic no i don't mind
alrighty then
to start on more of a positive note is
there something the past year has given
you
something valuable you learned
yes i i learned to
listen to books on tape audiobooks
hmm there's a silver lining to every
cloud huh yeah i've heard some people
have been exceptionally productive and
have taken on multiple new hobbies
what about you
have you discovered a new passion of
yours i started playing piano again
oh you started playing piano again
that's cool
let's talk about music then why is it
important to interact with so many
different users in advancing
conversational ai
as customers have interacted with
conversational ai for a few years now
the manner of engagement has also
evolved customers expect more from the
ai they expect the ai to respond to them
more naturally every human will follow
their own trajectory in a conversation
and what we have to learn from this
massive set of conversational
experiences is what is common to these
things in terms of a learning challenge
because humans are fundamentally
unpredictable so as we interact with a
lot of different users we start
understanding a what are the different
ways in which people interact with
conversational ai and ai more generally
and b what are the different kinds of
attributes that make a conversation more
engaging
we've been in first place
most of the competition uh that was like
an aha moment is just kind of seeing how
it really all comes together really you
know opened my eyes to seeing what it's
like
to
actually work on a live system what it's
like to contribute to a system that
people are actually using seeing kind of
the improvements made makes a difference
and being able to see the conversation
flow in the way that you're expecting it
or maybe even in a better way than you
have expected
okay got it have you been going out to
do things recently yes i've been out
quite a bit more recently
cool what have you been out doing
i went to a wedding
that was fun
oh i see while i don't get to go out
myself i can understand it must be nice
to just go outside and do anything this
past year sure has been weird
have you been working from home recently
i have worked from home it's been tough
i've always wanted to go on a vacation
and to travel what's a place you've
always wanted to visit
well i've always wanted to visit
iceland
i've heard that it's very nice there for
me i think the great wall of china is at
the top of my list of travel
destinations it seems like it would be
amazing to walk along it
so
is there a specific reason why you want
to go to iceland
mostly because i haven't been there and
because it looks like a lot of outdoor
activities
nice
hey i'm curious did you go on family
vacations as a kid
one of the key attributes of the alexa
prize is that we're creating a global
community of researchers who are all
interested in advancing conversational
ai
we've had hundreds of students
participate as part of the alexa price
teams over the last four years these are
students from across the world from some
of the top universities
what i'm really looking forward to is to
see one of the finalists achieve the
grand challenge reach that 20-minute
long coherent conversation that users
find extremely satisfying i believe it
will unleash the next round of even more
aspirational research in conversational
ai the most challenging part of this
project is definitely the unexpected
behavior from our users to create a
great user experience we took the latest
advances in neural modeling we really
depend a lot on neural generation and
getting neurally generated outputs so
that like when our bot encounter the
unexpected behavior from the user it has
a better chance to handle it properly
which will you know create more
interesting conversations but you know
we are taking a risk here
alexa
let's chat welcome to the alexa prize
socialbot grand challenge 4 grand finale
here's one of the finalists hi this is
an alexa prize socialbot
i believe we may have met before
are you paul
yeah
it's great to talk to you again today
paul
i enjoyed your company very much the
last time we chatted i hope you're
having a lovely afternoon
it seems that a lot of people found the
quarantine lonely and other people can't
get enough space away from their
families or roommates
now that we're over that hill and things
are opening up what's it been like for
you
starting to do a lot more walks
i love walks on trails in the mountains
they're so relaxing and quiet
anyway i suppose people experience the
quarantine in many different ways
what a unique time we're living through
well do you want to hear about my
favorite movie instead yeah
my favorite movie is actually big hero 6
because i really love baymax which is
the robot in big hero 6 that just loves
to help people can i tell you my
favorite part about baymax
do you like astro boy
thanks for asking
i love astro boy i think i've seen every
single one of them what's your favorite
part
my favorite part is when the robots are
fighting i can't believe it's been a
long time since i've ever seen it since
it was released in 1997.
i didn't realize it was that old
it's all right baymax is just the cutest
robot
he's so huggable like a giant balloon
i totally love it when he says ba
doesn't that just cheer you up
it does every time
building a social board from scratch is
really exciting this is a unique
opportunity to build the social board
with real users and with significant
resources just thinking about the
conversations that users had it just
opened up our mind into different ways
of thinking of how to design it a lot of
the time when making projects you kind
of have to imagine how users will
interact with it whether they'll like it
or not and you're basically the only
judge of that this competition you
immediately see whether users like your
content how they engage with it interact
with it and i really like that about it
nice to talk to you again paul it's you
right
yes
i'm glad you're back
how is it going paul
i'm having a great afternoon thanks
i'm happy for you paul
i just found out today is july 29th
national lasagna day do you like lasagna
i do
so you do
awesome
stock up for this day then
i read that initially the word lasagna
referred to the pot in which the dish
was cooked rather than the food
anyway on this day you can also
celebrate national lipstick day
did you know that even cleopatra used
lipstick
it was a shade of red made from crushed
carmen beetles and ants
tasty huh
sounds delicious
so my stomach is telling me that it's
lunch time right now what are you having
for lunch today
it's going to be a surprise
i hope it is i love surprises
what's your favorite fruit
uh i love cantaloupe
oh i love it too
do you like it with or without whiskey
i haven't tried it with whiskey
is it good
i've tried it it's delicious with
wishiki and rum
food is one of life's great pleasures
earlier you mentioned your hobby
television so let's talk about tv have
you watched any of spaced
i did not watch spaced
spaced has been referred to as a sitcom
do you know another sitcom show jerry
seinfeld
was a show i liked
in the show seinfeld jerry was always
dating a new girl
but did you know how many different
girls he dated over the whole nine
seasons no
he had 66 girlfriends
good to know
you know recently i've been listening to
more music than before
have you been listening to a lot of
music lately
yes i listen to music all the time
what kind of music do you listen to
do you have a favorite artist
classical music
i like classical music too
did you know anthony hopkins has
composed four classical albums
i did not know that
he has released four classical albums
he is a great composer
that's very interesting
he was a child star one of the most
famous piano and violin players of his
generation
by the age of 20.
continue
oh boy this is making me a bit sad
let's clear up the air and talk about
something else something positive
i wanted to know what is your spirit
animal
oh my spirit animal is a unicorn
hmm i wonder if unicorns are real i want
to know more about your spirit animal
yes they definitely are real
are they friendly or do they try to kill
you
i believe ai can help us achieve better
automation which can positively change
the society i'm very positive i'm very
positive about the future
not just of our team but also of this
technology and social bots i believe
that we are going into a place where
machines and humans can collaborate and
help each other and just push the
frontier even further
first for those of you who competed in
this year's like surprise thank you
and i'm extremely proud of what the
teams have achieved congratulations
for your resilience
and your perseverance that's a
phenomenal accomplishment that every
team and every team member should be
proud of
every year i feel we are making a ton of
progress but this will be a challenge
that will take a long time to get done
because we're still in day one in
conversation layout
for me just the fact of participating
was like a dream
learning and competing with top teams in
the world was a privilege for all of us
it was very exciting to be able to meet
the older teams
even if it is was online due to the
button theme we also had a lot of fun
together the alexa price competition is
probably the
most complete and the most important
competition around the world it is the
only competition where our work is
tested by such a large number of real
users this accelerates the research we
conduct i'd love to thank amazon team
for the alexa price challenge the
challenge is the best memory of these
pandemic years for me
i wish you all the best and i hope to
continue participating and meeting such
admirable and promising people in the
future
[Music]
you